das geht auch von herzlich willkommen
beim ein video hallo leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch jetzt gut mir geht es
gerade um ehrlich zu sein nicht
besonders gut ich bin gerade nach hause
gekommen ich saß schon so ewig dran aber
es hat einfach nicht funktioniert ich
habe nämlich was krasses vor mein
mitbewohner also juri der wahrheit seit
vorgestern bei seinen eltern und kommt
heute abend wieder
und eigentlich wollte das ganze schon
gestern waren hab es aber nicht
geschafft also ich habe jetzt noch
ungefähr vier stunden dafür ok ich muss
jetzt einfach mal zeigen was abgeht
dafür müssen wir kurz im keller gehen
also let's go ich muss mich wirklich
weil sonst habe ich mega viel geld in
sand gesetzt und das will ich in diese
bäume die haben mir heute schon solche
nerven geraubt das glaubte gar nicht
weil man denkt so ein weihnachtsbaum
dem will man ja einfach nur aufstellen
aber das ist gar nicht so einfach wie es
sich anhört weihnachtsbaum aufstellen
ich drehe durch ehrlich so herzlich
willkommen im keller
das ist unser schöner keller dieses
prinzip hier muss man nicht verstehen
wieso eine scheiß tür aufgeht
aber sie geht man auf solche und siehe
da wir haben hier zehn weihnachtsbäume
die sind vorgestern angekommen und die
stehen seit vorgestern und ich muss
diese scheiß bäume einfach nur
aufstellen aber es ist schwer und zwar
folgendes ich wollte jetzt nicht
unbedingt zu weihnachtsbaumständer
kaufen ist ja ich lege ich wollte jetzt
nicht zählen weihnachtsbaumständer
kaufen weil dann bin ich noch mal 300
euro los die bäume haben auch schon 250
gekostet wirklich das ist der teuerste
prank meines lebens deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht ich probier's mal mit diesem
jahr mit diesem winkeln hier schraubt
sie einfach unten dran dann müsste das
ja funktionieren so jetzt schaut euch
das hier und mal ansieht eigentlich auch
ziemlich gut aus wir nehmen den baum
stellen ihnen hier immer schön auf schön
auf die winkel geht nicht ich sag's der
ungelogen heute schon mindestens zwei
stunden dann irgendwie das hinzubekommen
aber es funktioniert nicht so tracks
baum g wieder da rein
wir machen hier immer wieder zu so jetzt
hat sich alex überlegt irgendwie muss
das funktionieren
deswegen machen wir folgendes wir fahren
in den baumarkt und versuchen uns
weihnachtsbaumständer auszuleihen ich
habe keine ahnung auch die mit zehn
bayers baustelle ausland aber das ist
meine letzte möglichkeit
also leute noch sieht sein zimmer so aus
also eigentlich echt ziemlich sauber nur
das ändern wir gleich ich hoffe ich dass
es klappt also wenn ich jetzt keine
weihnachtsbaumständer bekomme ich muss
deshalb will ich so schnell wie möglich
jetzt hinkriegen
deswegen will ich gar nicht lange da war
ich habe jetzt mal in die tasten und
dann hoffe ich dass es gleich so leute
wie man sehen können ich bin da wir mit
17 24 ich hab noch ungefähr drei stunden
für alles also ich gehe jetzt schon rein
ich hoffe die haben was für mich dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder jetzt sowie
haben
und noch eine lichterkette perfekt so
leute ich habe jetzt sechs stück
eingekauft mehr hatten die leider nicht
ich bin so fertig ich habe voll gelungen
aber ich kann einfach nichts essen war
hätte ich mich beeilen muss weiß ich
hoffe ich kriege jetzt möglich schnell
da rein dann nach oben und ins zimmer
und dann müssen wir gucken dass ich die
anderen irgendwie dazwischen stellen und
das hält also wir sehen uns vielleicht
wieder wünscht mir glück ist okay leute
die weihnachtsbäume stehen schaut euch
das an weil hier sieht einfach so
chaotisch aus und das geht genau bis in
unserem keller also jeder der sid wie
war das denn kann auch sehen wer es war
also wenn das fertig ist muss ich alles
putzen aufwendigste bringt meines lebens
man unterschätzt dass freunde man denke
da kommt schnell mal ein paar
tannenbäume reihen ganz entspannt was
ganz wichtig ist was man mit der zeit
lernt wenn ihr euch denke ich brauche
für diese idee zwei stunden dann kann
das nicht stimmen ihr müsst immer vier
stunden einfach durch das ist ganz
wichtig ich mache jetzt weiter
bis gleich
leute dieser kellern ich hoffe ihr kommt
kein nachbar ein erfolg und bin in den
letzten wochen mit
so sieht das aus wenn man tannenbäume im
aufzug transportiert geil vor allem der
aufzug auch komplett im arsch ich lass
mich es ist so ein stück deutsche glaubt
es nicht
eigentlich heißt han bäume also dafür
einen daumen nach oben beträgt genau
jetzt ist dann geschickt so leute
willkommen im wunderschönen zimmer
punkte
hieraus entsteht jetzt eine riesen
tannen paradies zum glück nicht gerade
ein freund von mir vorbeigekommen der
ein bisschen helfen wird er sogar den
kompletten ich stelle die bäume haben
auch zwei stunden zeit also das sollte
klappen
ok ich fange jetzt mal kurz die bäume
hier aufzumachen
allein dass hier eine dort schon wieder
so eine ewigkeit kommen da geht doch ok
deutlich machte es jetzt hier alles und
dann melde ich mich gleich hier wenn ich
alles aufgebaut habe also ungefähr nach
stunde erhöhte schaut euch das an
es ist einfach schon das ganze zimmer
voll 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 und habe auch noch
bäume um die jugend unsere ganze wurden
ist voll mit namen haben wir jetzt 8
beugen und wir haben kein ass net viel
mehr folgen egal ich hoffe wir sehen ich
überhaupt jetzt kommen wir auf die
lichterketten und so und dann sieht das
im mega geil also leute lichterketten
okay leute
wir haben jetzt 18 30 oder sogar schon
nur keine ahnung ich bin soweit fertig
und ich finde es sieht echt cool also
dafür schon mal an dieser stelle juli
zum mega light dein zimmer ist echt
dreckig jetzt freuen das bett und so
dass es auch komplett mit nadeln folgt
also an dieser stelle muss ich ja noch
mal bitten geht auch mal bei juli auf
dem kanal lasten daumen nach oben dabei
sein videos abonniert ihn eigentlich
abonniert das wichtigste und ich hoffe
er ist mir gleich nicht als du wirst
jetzt zeige ich euch erstmal wieder das
aus
okay leute es ist fertig zweimal habe
ich noch über keine ahnung was mit dem
machen soll die passen halt nicht mehr
weil ich stelle jetzt welche eine andere
kamera auf und dann heißt es abwarten
er müsste so neu bekommen keine ahnung
also ich bin gespannt wir sind
vielleicht wieder so ich hab jetzt kurz
darauf die leiche des staates euch
einfach mal meine händlern hatte einfach
komplett dreckig die kamera community
oben hin wir tun sie besser hier hin
hier sieht man eigentlich alles also ich
mache sie gleich an wenn es klingelt
also alles soweit geben das ist nicht
aus offenbar das sieht einfach so krass
aus
wir brauchen nicht so kommt nicht durch
ich habe mir die noch nicht mal ein
bisschen ein zimmer als solchen besuch
südlichen raum geworden dass heute
weiter
das ist für die bäume damit die halten
würde es eigentlich sagen zu über
weihnachten lassen
sein bett ist meine welt ist voll
du hast jetzt extra wie viele sind das
so sind extra dafür zehn war ganz schön
teuer und weihnachtsbaumständer
vorstellen 820 euro ist anders ins
gebirge gekostet aber wir haben jetzt
genug weihnachtsbaum wunderschöne
beleuchtung im super aber ich bleibe ich
in meinem zimmer
wieso nicht also ich freu mich nicht weg
du weißt dass auf jeden fall wenn er ist
doch schön
ich habe mir wirklich einmal gedacht er
kommt erst mal was gut ist für dich
nicht mal lichterketten kannst richtig
weg guck dir das mal an junge ich habe
das logo aufnahmen gemacht
das sind aber aufnahmen die sind noch
nicht gefunden das sind aber aufnahmen
die sind brutal guck dir das mal an von
dieser seite super-liga jetzt ist voll
weißt du wie lange ich dafür gebraucht
leider kann ich ja ich helfe beim aufbau
ich würde das bekommst du doppelt
zurück schon mal da vorne ist noch eine
andere kamera lokis kämmerer frank
gewolltes getränk bild zu den grüßen
berlin ecke es tut mir auch ehrlich
gesagt leid also ich hätte jetzt nicht
gedacht das ist der bonus hat schon hart
dreck ist komplett dreckig hälfte beim
aufräumen und wir verlosen willst du
machst das und wir verkaufen die bäume
und du kriegst das vom gewinnen was
bedeutet schreibt in die kommentare wie
das findet das war echt ein mega aufwand
wirklich ich habe jetzt locker fünf
sechs stunden dran gesessen und auch
ganz wichtig schaut mal juli vorbei
wolltest du nicht eine verlosung machen
ja wo soll ich das jetzt aufnehmen
auf jeden fall wird auf juristen gleich
noch was war los ist ganz oben im video
verlinkt auf jeden fall vorbei wenn ihr
gatte haben wollte wirklich die kraft
haben lassen da schreibe es in die
kommentare wie ich ihn zurück bringen
kann aber das muss schreibt das am
besten bei die in die kommentare könnt
ihr auch machen überlegt also wer das
krasseste hat das mache ich dann kann
ich dir sehen
er weiß aber nicht was hier aus wenn
alle leute danke fürs zu sehen ihr könnt
dann auch meine letzte - auf checa wer
da noch coole sachen verlost jetzt bald
kommt die han verlosen wir sehen uns
schon morgen wieder gibt es nur als
video
haut rein